Hello, I'm very thrilled
to have a conversation
with costume designer
Arianne Phillips, who
is an Academy member
and a three-time Oscar
nominee for her work on
Walk the Line, W.E. and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood.
Today we're going to
talk about her work
specifically on Hedwig
and the Angry Inch.
So Arianne, thanks very
much for joining us.
I am thrilled to have you here.
First thing I want to do
is thank you for the items
that you've donated to the
Academy's library and museum.
Would you like to talk
a little bit about what
some of those things were?
Sure, thank you Randy for
having me in anticipation
of the opening of the museum.
I am so excited to be part of
anything and everything AMPAS
museum so I really
appreciate being here.
And being able to talk about
one of the most important films
in my personal trajectory
as a costume designer.
Hedwig is, I would say
probably at the center point
of the most meaningful--
one of the most
meaningful and sustainably
creative experiences
that keeps on going
as the appreciation
and the love for Hedwig 20
years later is not lost on me,
so thrilled to talk about it.
And yes.
For many years
I've been donating
my sketches and visual materials
to the Margaret Herrick Library
with wonderful Anne
Coco over there,
and it's just been
such a wonderful asset
to be able to have a place where
the work can live on and be
there if anybody's
interested in looking at it
and it can be taken care of and
looked after and, of course,
in the vault of history, of
our own history as filmmakers.
So my journey in
terms of donations
really started with that
relationship with Anne Coco.
And over the years, I've donated
many sketches, some of which
are Hedwig sketches.
And then when I got news that
the museum would be collecting
specific pieces, costume
pieces, for their archive,
I think there is a
ripple of excitement
through our community
and me especially because
of all the films
that I've designed,
Hedwig happens to be
the only film in which I
own the costumes which was
part of my initial deal
that I made with the producers
given that it was a small indie
film.
And it was to offset the
lack of compensation.
I said, well, I'll
keep the costumes.
And yeah, I've been
holding on to them.
And here and there people
will come over to my studio
and look at them
and get so much joy.
You never know when
you're working on a film
how it will resonate
with the audience.
And Hedwig is just
such a special movie
and that generationally
people are responding to it.
And it's become a classic in
its own kind of outsider way.
So I guess it was
very fortunate of me
to be able to make that
deal with the producers
that I could keep the costumes
and now have the opportunity
to donate them to the museum
so that future generations
and our community, if people
are interested in, can see them
and someday maybe they'll
make it on exhibition.
And the thing about paper
materials and textiles,
costumes, is that they
can deteriorate over time.
Lose their luster, their
color, the quality.
So knowing that
these costumes are
being preserved under the
curation of the museum
is just thrilling.
Fantastic, thank you
so much for that.
And I just want to say
that these costumes, even
though they happen to
be the only set you have
from your work, it's a great
set to have because they
are such iconic images and I
think they also are just fun.
There's a lot of times when you
watch a film and the costumes
feel like they're just
part of the natural story
and you're not really paying
that much attention to them,
even though they are things
that make an impression
subconsciously
about the character.
But in the case
of Hedwig, they're
just such definitive
pieces that immediately
you get a new piece of the
Hedwig personality every time
a costume appears.
And I know you had like
41 costumes for Hedwig
to do in that film.
Just for John Cameron Mitchell.
Yeah, there you go.
There are thousands
of costumes in movie
but, thank you for saying that.
I mean, I think the thing
about costume design
is its character development
and character illustration.
So the great thing
about Hedwig is
people have a tendency to see
it more than once, like Rocky
Horror Picture
Show so you know--
your second time, or maybe
even your third if you're lucky
or fourth, you'll see different
layers of story in there not
only with the costumes but also
with the wonderful production
design by Thérèse DePrez
And I think the wonderful thing
about John Cameron Mitchell
as a director is he
really encouraged
us to create layers of story.
And whether it was
something hidden or seen
that would inform us in
the making of the movie.
So yeah, there are
lots of things.
The story is such
a wonderful journey
that you might need to see
the second time to really get
some of the high moments.
Or 22nd time, it depends.
Some people need a lot of
time to soak it all in.
So anyway--
Whatever it takes.
It's a movie that's
fun to re-watch.
I know that it's hard to
choose among your children
when you have 41
children in representing
John's costumes in this film.
But at the same time, I
literally gasped when I saw,
for lack of a better term,
the hair or probably better
to call it the wig dress.
It's the hair dress.
We call it the hair dress.
The hair dress.
Either way it fits into a nice
double entendre type of thing.
I think that the fun
thing about that is you
can just see the
sheer joy that he's
having performing in that--
The Terror.
Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
There's a fine line between
joy and terror as we all know.
And that's a dress
too that I think
the craftsmanship
of that dress really
shows, because it moves
in just a particular way
and it just feels
so organic and I'm
sure that was not
the easiest thing
to put together and make work.
Just my own personal
favorite there.
Oh, thank you.
It's one of my favorites too.
I mean, if think about
it, John Cameron Mitchell
as the director was directing
every day in full make-up,
wigs, and high heels.
So why not add a
dress made of a wig.
It's too much.
So we have some Polaroids that
if somebody saw them laying
on a table might just casually
think they were snapshots
or whatever.
But I'm assuming that they
were actually reference photos
that you were taking,
and maybe some of them
were for fun too I don't know.
But they're really unique
images from that period of work.
So let's take a look.
Let's do a little slideshow
of some of your own Polaroids.
Yes so one of the things,
I miss Polaroid so much.
I always had a
Polaroid camera with me
on set around this time.
And I was just so
marveled, like I said,
that and John Cameron
Mitchell not only
was starring as Hedwig, but
he was directing himself.
And here he is checking
the shot before he's
in the scene in full wig,
make-up, and costume.
And I was just--
he popped up on the dolly that
to check the shot before he ran
in front of the camera and
I was in constant awe of him
and I just love this shot.
It just made me laugh with
the Chinese daily special
behind him.
This is from a fitting.
This costume became
pretty iconic
because it was on the
poster for a while.
And this is John without,
of course, wig and make-up.
Yeah, one of the things
usually in fittings, it's
always great when the
actors are able to have
the wig on especially
if it's a different hair
color and the make-up.
This was, I think,
one of those days
where John being the director
was so over scheduled.
We did the fitting
without the wig
and he's playing, having a
good time in the fitting.
And I just thought it was such a
great costume in process photo.
This is from the set from
John Cameron Mitchell wearing
that hair dress that
we spoke about earlier.
This is from the set
of "Wig in the Box,"
which is like a music
video within the film.
It's the one kind of magical
reality fantasy moment
and we actually shot
this, I was reminded,
I think on our last
day of shooting.
And it was-- we were doing it
at twilight and our production
designer Thérèse
DePrez such a genius,
had rigged this trailer wall
so that it would fall down
and there are these stage
lights in the corner.
So here we are in
between setups.
You can see a fan
in the background
because it was hot as hell in
the summer in Toronto shooting.
And John in high
heels, of course,
taking a break patiently
waiting for his next set up.
This is the iconic
Hedwig costume.
This costume of repurposed
denim romper and this cape
that mimics the Berlin Wall.
All the art was done by this
incredible artist Miguel
Villalobos.
Hedwig the movie is based on an
Off-Broadway play in New York.
And in the play, Hedwig
only had one costume.
I didn't design the play,
but this was the film version
of that recycled denim
costume that was so famous
in the Off-Broadway production.
This is a scene when Hedwig is
prostituting in the Meatpacking
District in New York
and Tommy Gnosis
comes in and picks her up.
This is an on-set
photo that I took.
I was inspired by
a fashion designer
friend of mine,
Jeremy Scott, who
had done this collection and
this idea of the kind of one
leg trouser and so we
did our Hedwig version.
So John's wearing
a thigh-high boot
that he wore in the "Wig
in the Box" costume.
And what I would say about
the costumes in general,
is they're "method
costumes" in that,
every costume I
felt that we created
I had to be in the head of
Hedwig of how she would have
created this for herself.
Because she is a DIY character,
do it yourself person.
So that's what this
Polaroid shows,
a little gold razor blade.
There's a lot of
humor and a wink
and a nod in a lot
of these costumes.
This is this from the set.
This is at the end of the
song, "Exquisite Corpse" where
Hedwig really just--
I made this dress
out of plastic.
Actually, we had to
make multiples of them,
and they were wrapped
literally plastic bags.
And we built up
the plastic so much
that I was able to sew trim
on and I put grommets in it.
And this is a scene
when Hedwig has really
come to a point where she
is tired of the artifice,
and rips her dress
and it's the crescendo
of the end of the film and ends
up leaving the stage naked.
So this is the stripping away of
the artifice of this, you know,
and gender.
This is really an
interesting conversation now
that we're having
culturally about gender.
And this is really about Hedwig
not subscribing to gender
and just being true
to who Hedwig is.
Aha!
The hair dress.
So my partner in crime
on the hair dress
is I enlisted genius
wig designer and make-up
artist, Mike Potter.
Who created Hedwig, the original
wig and the make-up design
with John back in
the clubs of New York
before it was an
Off-Broadway show.
And Mike has been part
of Hedwig's evolution
from the clubs of New York
to Off-Broadway to the movie.
And then we all were reunited
on Broadway a few years ago.
So Mike Potter, I
enlisted his expertise
once we sewed these wig wefts.
They're called wefts.
Wefts of hair, like
a fringe curtain.
And this was a Saturday,
a day off during shooting
in our hotel room in Toronto.
And I think John ended up just
crying in the middle of this,
he was so tired.
But we were listening
to loud music
and giving the
costume a haircut.
This is a scene from set, a
Polaroid on set from the Menses
Fair, which is a
riff on the, I guess,
the Lilith Fair of the 90s.
And actually, this
piece was designed
by this really wonderful
independent designer,
fashion designer named Grey Ant.
And he was generous
enough to loan this to me
for the shooting of the movie.
And I loved it for its scale
and volume and it's oversized.
It's like a top, you can't
see the rest of the costume.
But it was perfect
for the scene and it
was that was a beautiful
day we were shooting.
So here we go.
So here's a fitting
where John actually
has a stand-in wig
so we could get
a sense of what the hair would
look like with the costume.
This is a costume in progress
that we made for "Sugar Daddy."
The song "Sugar Daddy"
when Hedwig literally
gives a quote unquote,
"car wash" to a customer
Bilgewaters.
So there's John in a
very enthusiastic pose
during the fitting.
This is a shot from the
set that I was lucky enough
to get close in on of
Michael Pitt and Hedwig
on set shooting the scene
from the trailer park.
And I particularly
love this Polaroid,
the lighting just
worked out beautifully.
And there's like a--
I love the expression
on John's face,
there's like a poignancy to
this photo that is so sweet.
And here's from the same
session of them, I guess,
I busted them.
I caught a private
moment and then
maybe they were rehearsing
in between setups
I can't remember, probably.
And here they are being--
we just had so
much fun on the set
it was so great to
see these smiles
and be reminded of that
time shooting together,
it was really special.
Here we are again at the
monitors for that "Wig
in the Box" scene.
John, as the
director, of course,
in full costume with
Frankie DeMarco.
You can see right
next to John who's
the DP the cinematographer,
and they're talking,
I'm sure about the shot.
Behind John is Miriam
Shor, who plays Yitzhak.
And behind Miriam in white
you see Stephen Trask,
who's the lyricist and
co-creator of Hedwig.
And I don't remember the
other people unfortunately,
it's been 20 years but
crew members there.
So that is on set.
You can see we have
a pop-up over us.
I think it was threatening
rain that night,
a humid Toronto summer.
Here is a shot of
John in between takes
at the beginning of the
song "Exquisite Corpse"
in that plastic dress
which was really
created building up layers
and layers of basically
plastic bags and clear tape.
And then we put grommets and I
sewed in like a beaded fringe
on the bottom.
And this is John's costume for
"Exquisite Corpse," of course.
We saw in the other Polaroid
when he rips it off.
It's the crescendo of
"Exquisite Corpse."
This is just an artistic shot
I did on set with the cape
from the opening costume
from "Tear Me Down."
John is so photogenic and
is such a brilliant actor,
let alone director.
And a muse really for me.
I took a lot of
pictures of John on set
because I thought he was
just so beautiful as Hedwig
and I was so moved
by his ability
to seamlessly move in front
and behind the camera,
so incredible.
Here we are in
that "Sugar Daddy"
costume behind the camera
probably getting a wig touch-up
as John always as
people know on set,
actors with a lot
of make-up have
to drink water with straws.
And just an in-between moment
on the set from shooting the car
wash scene, the
"Sugar Daddy" scene.
This might have
been a continuity
photo where I was trying to--
but maybe it was just
an artistic shot.
That wig always makes for such
a great frame on John's face.
So you can see the
costumes close up.
There's a little rabbit fur pull
on there and lots of crystals,
I always say I was my own
sweat shop on this movie.
There are only two of us in our
department, sometimes three.
And so it was actually a
really wonderful experience
having just come
off a big studio
film to work on an
independent film
where I was doing
everything and that
really helped me kind of
re-calibrate how important it
is.
Sometimes we get removed from
the set as costume designers
since we're always--
we're technically
an off-set position,
or we get removed from
the making of a costume.
So this is such a
memorable film for me
because I was able
to be involved
in all aspects of the costumes
from creation to being on-set.
And this is Mike Potter, the
genius wig designer and make-up
artist who created
Hedwig's look from day one.
From the nightclubs of New York
City to Off-Broadway Hedwig
to the film.
He was my partner in
crime and we were--
the costume is
really only completed
by the wig and make-up.
And we really, really
worked closely.
I don't think I've ever worked
so intimately with another hair
and make-up artist
so that was really
thrilling that we were able
to create these looks together
with different wigs.
That's Mike again.
Mike Potter who played a little
guest role as a prostitute
in the Meatpacking
District, a male prostitute.
Male drag prostitute in
the Meatpacking District.
But I think he's in
partial make-up there.
And Mike Potter again.
He is modeling the
Hedwig's sunglasses
that we see in the
beginning of the movie.
He was my muse as well.
And Mike Potter doing the hair
for one of the "hed heads,"
which are Hedwig's groupies.
This is Paul who is actually a
longtime friend of John Cameron
Mitchell.
John had a lot of his
friends play different parts
in the movie, it was a
real family atmosphere.
This is Michael Pitt in a
fitting for Tommy Gnosis, one
of his performance costumes.
And Michael was
incredible to work with.
Another Tommy Gnosis
costume fitting
with Michael Pitt
and another one.
I don't think that made the cut.
And this is a photo
of Michael Pitt
on set for that
trailer park scene
and I love the lighting out.
It's just by
chance, by accident,
that he's out of
focus and you get--
you can see the cables in
the right corner of the set
and then you can
see that painted
backdrop in the background.
So you really get a sense
of the movie-making aspect.
And that's him as young Tommy
before it becomes Tommy Gnosis.
And Michael Pitt
as Tommy Gnosis,
I believe that's on set because
that's a costume t-shirt.
I don't think it's a fitting.
Probably in-between takes and
probably rehearsing guitar.
He did a lot of
rehearsing guitar.
And there's Michael
as Tommy Gnosis
with these fabulous
leather trousers
we made for him, as low as we
could go in that Jim Morrison
tradition.
Wanted these leather
pants to feel
like a second skin and the
way that Frankie DeMarco was
shooting it was
in very low light.
You also see Hedwig in
this scene coming out
of darkness so I'm very happy
with the way it turned out.
Well, that was really fantastic
Arianne, thank you so much.
It is great to feel
like we were on the set
and at the same time to be able
to look at the detail on some
of these Polaroids.
When you're watching
a film sometimes
the costumes are so busy moving
around that you don't really
get to see it so this
was a really fun way
to concentrate a little
bit more on your work
and at the same time celebrate
what was actually going
on 20 years ago, as you were
making the film, so thank you
so much.
Thank you so much for having me.